dude so many times I've been in that
situation with Nikki where she like told
me something and I just [__] answer
and then I'm like because I autopilot a
response right it's hard to follow am I
Really Gonna triple down that I that I
heard her and I'm like yeah
[Music]
hello and welcome back to another
episode of the careful boys what's up
careful boys you're currently off the
record I thought we're we're currently
careful that's that'd be cool currently
careful that's a cool thing oh that's
kind of a new cool thing you think we
still gotta be that careful it's not
locked down in covet and Crimson culture
is pretty much dead no yeah we should
never stop being here should we just
change our name to the book boys and
then just go full one well boys is only
half of us okay it's very exclusive yeah
you guys have to believe all women
walkie walks dude that's like something
that you say before you get stunner bro
and the huge pot from the crowd yeah so
uh here's the question that I have for
everybody
even if you can't quantify this into a
number you have to okay okay 19 mil on a
scale of one to ten
rate the current state of your
relationship oh oh uh like what your
significant with your significant other
yeah with your boyfriend Bart I would
say nine wow that's high yeah because
you always gotta leave room for
improvement very Asian I really do
believe that and because she's bringing
in all the dough and she's bringing all
the money no uh no it's for me it's like
um
nine because we are I think we have a
second hand that is unlike anything else
like like and what I mean by that is
like we got an argument the other night
over kitty litter right and I'm
screaming at her about kitty litter
she's breaking stuff in the house
screaming and screaming no but we we
have like a like so like I was just
doing kitty litter oh [__] and she was
like are you gonna ever do the kids
literally like I'm literally doing it
right now what the [__] that's your
argument yeah yeah that's husband and
wife stuff yeah it's just husband white
bickering stuff but we we get through it
so quickly and to the end of it so fast
like it was like a nine minute thing
damn yeah and then it's like done and
like we're moved on and then also I've
done this thing too where she gets um
like every year I try to get a little
bit better at something especially when
this [__] doubts me yeah and so like
when I and this is driven by pettiness
oh 100 I'm very I think we all know I'm
driven when he gets the wrong [__] at
the supermarket all the time exactly oh
yeah one day doesn't know where the
mailbox is
the trash
it was personal for me and and I and I
and you know what it never happened
since and you know what the milk thing
never happened since and you know what I
make her breakfast now like every
[__] day what do you make I make eggs
and I make toes
sausage she doesn't eat the sausage
because she's trying to make turkey
bacon she doesn't eat the turkey bacon
but I make her breakfast and then I also
started making like just like I make her
vegan tacos like every week like no
matter what I make it every week would
you do all these things if you were
making more money than her no
but that's that's the coolest part right
I like taking care of her that was part
of my wedding vows was like cool you
know you don't you don't um
I I don't uh I want to take care of you
not because you need to be taken care of
but because I need to take care of you
and I just really feel like that is like
my long travel yeah with her yeah you're
a sweet sweet boy oh I love this chick
man so so then um so I started cooking
for her right regularly and anytime
she's hungry like for breakfast I make
it and she expects it now which is cool
because she used to make fun of me about
my eggs she's to say Steve can't cook
and now she can't say that [__] anymore
how do you do your eggs how do you do it
over easy I do over easy yeah she got
you so figured out she wants breakfast
she knows how to work me so she just
talks [__] and you she gets breakfast
every day she talks [__] about how I'm
not a handyman and I installed our
washer dryer she's like Steve did she
still talks [__] about how it spilled
water everywhere we all saw that yeah
yeah she's talked [__] pretty good
you love it though I love it
getting my balls busted it's [__]
hilarious how I grew up but she's such a
good bulb she's so good at it I know I
was with the chick who couldn't bust
balls and I was so bored I've never been
how lucky for you that you ended up with
someone that can speak that well and
bust balls so hard better than anybody
yeah it's no it's the best plus baller
three thousand hundred percent but then
um okay so then okay I cook for all that
stuff I do handyman [__] and then I know
that she's challenging Me by like going
you can't do this and then she knows
like I know that same thing about her if
I say she can't do something she does
the same exact [__] so so we both kind
of have that with each other but that's
why I give us a nine because I think
I've been with her for six years of
marriage this month it'll be 10 years
this month that we were together
and uh and I'm honest to God love her
more than I ever did does that include
you guys being a couple yeah 10 years oh
10 years I see six years of marriage and
yeah I love her more than I ever but
would you say like there's been moments
of maybe the relationship's been 7 out
of 10 and then it's been an eight out of
ten somewhere like whatever I would say
in the early days it was like a five out
of ten or even lower during that time
did you feel like it was a 5 out of ten
or you're looking back in retrospect now
and saying oh it's [__] nine felt
like it was a five out of ten because I
was this [__] was pissed me off so much
yeah I couldn't even believe it yeah and
it wasn't in like break bus balls since
it was like genuinely
we could not communicate correctly like
you had
um you were bumping heads because you
were actually misunderstanding Each
Other Well we were doing [__] debate
class where I have my opinion she has
her opinion and nobody's rooting for
each other's point to win we're just
cable TV yelling at each other
and now we do this thing where we're
rooting for each other's position
because we love each other so there's
the Bedrock of Love Is Right boom boom
boom right trying to understand instead
of fight for for the winning yeah you
got into recently right you're like oh
well hunt like I didn't know that so
like I think most
most relationships are like this where
you want to be heard first and foremost
you want to win when you say let's talk
it really means listen to me yes it
doesn't mean like like we need to come
together on an agreement and also in a
lot of the times it sucks when both
parties have to sacrifice because no one
wins right it's better to just
understand each other's points but
that's so [__] hard to do because for
one most of us I'd say half of the
population if we all grew up in a broken
home we don't know what conflict
resolution looks like two
if you've been in shitty situations you
carry that over from the past and you
dump that on the next girl and vice
versa she'll do that to you too right so
no one knows how to root for each other
and it's so easy to feel offended and
angered that like all you care about is
like oh well you don't want to listen I
don't listen to you and I think that was
very that's very very normal until in
this relationship it was really like
um I think also because she's not an
aggressive person she'll stand her
ground logically and she's really good
at that but she's not aggressive so that
the the she's frustrated but I never
feel like she's frustrated at me she's
frustrated that we can't solve the
situation so I don't feel attacked and
then so then I feel like she's got my
back it's everything yeah and anything
that helps because she said yeah I I'm
lucky I grew up with parents that love
each other and then I watched how they
would fight and scream but there was
still love at the end of the day and
then there was resolve and then so for
me I know that like there's resolve and
if for you it's like bounce divorce get
the [__] out it's not working we don't
have an agreement we have a disagreement
this is not working out and she
understood that so I think that that's
what really helped my growth in how I
resolve conflict with with her yeah it's
you want to have each other's backs and
I think that that really I wish more
people had that perspective of like they
still love their partner so much that
they want to understand what the
disconnect is and they want to fix they
want to fix this so it doesn't become a
bigger situation if I could just convey
one thing to people it would be that
like if you if you have a real
relationship that's mature and strong
and built with trust you can get there
quickly right and you should be always
building towards that like how can I
understand you and what you mean and
what you need from this situation
what would you say our number's at now
10. damn well I mean it can be perfect
no no I would say
well also I'm kind of it's a new
relationship still you know it's a
couple of years in it's funny because
you know I would I would assume that
yours would start at a peak and then
reality hits because you're not
infatuated anymore right where I don't
even know at my age if I'm capable of
infatuation so then it never started at
infatuation because the intention was
never let's get together
yeah yeah yeah
nice yeah nine and ten nice
any tubes
what's yours nick uh I think it's like a
seven okay interesting uh what's going
on
yeah I'm ready every day I've been like
oh I'm gonna divorce you so hard
uh I think it's on me kind of oh yeah
just haven't really been um you've
deflect towards her too she'd be like
what's really wrong and I'll be like
[Laughter]
I love meta Nick
so good Nick mad at Nick
I think work is the thing right now lack
of presence where I'm just not at home
enough but dude you're working for the
family too that's what I'm saying yeah
when you're at home are you is it
because you're not all like
are you still thinking about work no I
think when I'm home when I'm present for
the couple hours I'm home I'm very
present uh maybe just my own guilt yeah
that's probably a lot of it too like I
feel like I'm not what are you doing
what do you feel guilty about
um just you know you look really cool
but right now by the way here we go
um I feel like I'm not in these puppies
lives as I need to okay no no but so now
that I do feel bad that I'm not like
there to help out because it is a lot
it's [__] two dogs and a lot of stuff
and Tiff works from home and all that so
I think she'll make jokes like like I'm
a single mom like oh you're not you're
never home and like she'll she'll
complain to our like our group of
friends yeah and it's like an ongoing
joke but then like later in the day
she'll be like hey just so you know like
I feel guilty for making those jokes
like
I know you're working I know you're
working hard I'm just messing around but
at the same time I do feel like dang
like I can't I know I'm working and I'm
trying to do all that stuff but I there
has to be a balance and I haven't found
it yet so that's been kind of
challenging
um but it's just not I'm not in that
position yet but eventually it'll it'll
even out yeah and then um next week we
have Nick's why I left JK video
I've been spending too much time you
can't really say why I left JK's 20
minutes of him Meandering and kind of
talking yeah I'm just like looking at
the lights the whole time
like you know I love you
but uh apologizing before he even makes
a point everyone's like wow I watched a
20 minute video and I still don't know
why you love JK
no one gets it it's kind of on brand
but maybe no maybe Seven's too low maybe
Seven's too low I mean if you can score
yourself honestly you say it's on you
you know I think I think it's on me I
think it's something and also like
you've had tens because you've been with
her for how long yeah I feel like our
first couple years has been a 10 bro
like it's been like Easy Street
um so
she's been yeah so that's that's been
interesting I think and trying to like
because I think it really is like on my
own guilt yeah yeah okay like I feel
kind of bad
you should I should I'm a piece of [__]
I should be home right now I'll see you
guys later you guys got the rest of the
videos right I have cancer for me yeah I
think mine's probably right now I would
say it's an eight
and that's because like
I think I find my own love language to
get kind of monotone in a weird way like
I think I just yeah I just find myself
doing a lot of the same [__] even though
I'm doing something for her sometimes I
just go like why am I not
trying other things I kind of feel the
same way you know what I mean you ever
like get tired of your own [__] yeah
it's I don't know that's every day bro
but then also like you want to like beat
yourself like do different things yeah
like you want to blow the socks off for
different ways every single time yeah
like just how you express your love for
someone you kind of start noticing your
own repetition in a way yeah your own
patterns now and that might just be me
and my own head but also uh we had we
had a lot of problems for a little bit
about like I always felt like it was
hard for us to build she she kind of has
like a not as great of a memory as I do
for just remembering random [__] uh and
so it's hard to build inside jokes with
her sometimes because she'll just be
like when did that happen and like I'll
do callbacks to [__] and she's like huh
like when was that and I felt like to
get a shot of the sky yeah yeah I
started to feel like [__] man like can't
you just and then she actually actively
worked on practicing like how to
remember like and she got better at how
do you do that like you gotta put shapes
on the table and cover the blanket you
have 30 seconds
brain teasers every day
I think that's what it's like notebook
dude I thought it was really adorable is
that she actually did look up how to
like how to remember that's [__]
awesome looked up methods on how to like
improve that and how do you know if
you're staying over a shoulder typing it
in for it
highly creative people are daydreamers
and they're like always in the blend of
reality and dreaming a little bit Yeah I
also this one's gonna make me look
really [__] up but like I felt we also
had a problem with like sometimes we'll
just have conversations and then she
just won't hear what I'm saying and then
like she'll just be like Oh I thought
you said this and we'd spend most of the
conversation clarifying what I was
really saying she has a mind of it she's
the guy she's the guy I would get really
pissed off like I'll get actually mad
because I'm like
lose my temper a lot and then turns out
if you're thinking about the NFL the
whole time turns out she actually has
like she actually uh has
like she got her ears tested and she has
like a massive
deficitors
so she can't actually hear you so it was
literally she couldn't hear she
literally could not he's not tasting
good stuff like Bart yeah so you're
probably talking and she's all like when
did you say that exactly so it's not it
wasn't so much that she can't remember
or hear it or that she just didn't hear
in the first place just can't she
doesn't know a lot of [__] she doesn't
know she's not listening to you
she's a [__] dude I think she's
trying she paid the doctor to get the
report that's a dude she paid the doctor
that's a guy
can you just tell him I have a ear
deficit please dude so many times I've
been in that situation with Nikki where
she like told me something and I just
been bullshitting an answer and then I'm
like because I autopilot response right
it's hard to follow yeah and she knows
that autopilot responds she's gonna talk
on a straight line and then I'm like am
I Really Gonna triple down that I that I
heard her and I'm like yeah yeah
[Laughter]
yeah why not I do the same [__] and then
later on they're like we talked about
this and I'm like when and she goes
remember we're in the car and we're like
oh yeah but you were talking about five
stories at once I couldn't catch that
[__] uh I was listening to you so hard
on the first story
and I was like and then I got distracted
by the left turn let's go guys
oh listen down I'm gonna use that one I
need more like hall passes
babe I was so absorbed by the first
story it's so rich and touchy she not
only so she has a hearing aid now no
what is this a what the doctor had to
prescribe her hearing how old is she
because her hearing is so it's so low
like it's drastically how does she
listen to music it hears it wax build up
yes because my brother has oh no it's
like an actual like
um so like you know as people get older
their hearing goes yeah hers is
happening way the [__] earlier than a
normal person just one of them I I I
think it might be both so she's like the
uh the Tessa Thompson in Creed exclusion
Creed I've seen Creed the chick that was
making music right yeah she literally it
was like a degenerative hearing yeah she
kind of has that so but you know on the
upside to that randomly
um randomly also absorbed in the first
story a hearing aid company did a brand
deal with it because of that and now
she's benefiting from it entirely so
yeah that's cool dude she does nothing
but wins yeah that was one of our
biggest things was like the
communication was hard because of your
ears yeah and the whole time you're just
like she couldn't hear yeah whole time
I'm getting mad that like you're not
even [__] paying attention she's like
so Earnest and she's like I am I swear I
felt so bad crying all right dude her
brand is so clean does she ever give you
[__] because you're on JK no because
like she's her brand is clean but I mean
she like when she talks to you guys in
person like she talks like I do yeah
that's cool yeah she's a dude in the
relationship does it ever yeah it never
gives you no she doesn't give a [__] she
does not she couldn't give less of [__]
of what I'm doing really doesn't care he
doesn't trip about all like the Dan
ex-girlfriends you have yeah she's
catching on the pattern
she's still alive it's been a long time
so you're saying you don't do the
memorization test with the blanket
how long have you guys been together
it's been almost eight almost eight
years yeah whoa damn that's not like a
long time what's your number right what
are you talking about dude what's your
number I can't remember
bird dog in that clock stop trying to
run the clock out man and he's like we
might have to part two this one boys I'm
so absorbed in the first story go ahead
ready
and give us another
[Laughter]
number he was listening
eight yeah I'll go eight right I don't
see it is bad though I'm impressed with
you as nine yeah it's good I would have
done 10 but I didn't want to outshine
you guys I won't change my answer ten
you're more than welcome now shy this
truck uh I'll say I also think we're all
like we got married late last year I
still think we're like on a on a high of
just life is very new in that committal
space even though we're now officially
uh nine years in together
does it feel like a reset when it
happened like it's something new it does
it feels like a new flavor even if it's
like the same meat it's like you've been
eating a burger with ketchup your whole
life and now you didn't take away the
ketchup you just added Mayo as well you
tell her that after you eat this changes
the entire thing go ahead go ahead the
relationships like we added mayonnaise
isn't it amazing anyways
um
I think that's amazing I think that
we're in like just a very good spot in
general but
I think similar to Nick I've just been
so consumed by work uh they're really
really busy yeah and then you feel like
a piece of [__] like me a little bit but
I'm like I also feel like a piece of
[__] sometimes when I have to like fight
for the idea that I'm busy because I'm
fighting for the house but again just
like you said I think you articulated
well like there's also still a balance
but I don't know if I've necessarily
found it but you know like I'm also not
in like consistent work I'm in like gig
work so when a gig comes in I'm like I
gotta run with that gig and that gig
might take everything from me for a
short period of Time Versus like this is
my career for the next five years I
might be homeless on a month you know
yeah you know like I definitely know
what it feels like to have like you know
pockets of times where I don't have big
gigs or anything like that so like when
something does come in I'm like I'm
moving [__] mountains to try and make
that thing work which is why even
sometimes I gotta bounce on JK because
I'm like I don't know if I'm gonna get
this up again even though if you zoom
out
I I'm always gonna get an opportunity
yeah you always get something yeah you
know you just you never know what it is
when it's going to come but you want to
knock it out the Park yeah and you know
so I just also feel like I haven't been
around as much whereas conversely you
she has a consistent job from Monday to
Friday yeah so her weekends are weekends
yeah my weekends are oftentimes work
time you know what I mean so our off
schedule hours are like very very not
consistent with each other so when she's
coming home
you know from work she's already tired
but maybe that's like this is our time
together because when the weekend hits
I gotta go to work yep you know what I
mean so I think we're trying to still
find like a life balance that it's not
super complimentary but we're in a good
spot what we're cool man that was very
articular that was way better than what
I said but yeah it took and it took less
time the Barton Geo number dude it's
probably low look at the time
did you did she talk to you about how
she found out about how you dropped
she tagged me in in the JK one where she
goes this is what happened when Bart
watched Titan it's a kid falling off
yeah I feel like we're like like 9.5 or
close to 10.
hey we're in we're all in good healthy
loving this is [__] I don't want to
be the last one it took us a long time
to get here but kind of like uh Steve's
like second hand thing like this is
probably the busiest I've ever been like
you know back and forth from Vegas in
here yeah you gotta make appearances of
powerless enough appearances do
different things uh we have a kid now so
that's like a third person that we're
like oh it's constantly tag teaming into
like WWE wrestling ring like taking hit
this who's taking a kid to school who's
picking up who's taking the Jiu Jitsu I
heard that um meanwhile balancing the
same working in the same company with
the pugs huh
while trying to like balance uh okay
like it's this mom's birthday this mom's
birthday and so it feels like we this is
the business we've been and there's like
all kinds of [__] going on
and sometimes we're
physically apart geographically apart
but our hearts are so like in sync it
doesn't matter if like I'm in Austin
Texas she's here or I'm in Vegas or
bouncing around or she's bringing taika
to go see a doctor because he has
seizures and [__] to see a doctor at
UCLA but I'm not there it just feels
like we're so like our we're above the
the busy mess and our hearts are just
together so it always feels like we're
on the same team trying to take care of
the same [__] even though there's like 5
000 everyone has 5 000 spinning plates
and we never have this feeling of like
oh you're spinning too many plates
you're not away from me because we have
the same Mission so you're taking a dig
at me in it
don't include me in your seven dude
assault him yeah I'm just taking this
personally right now but it's all like
you guys are blaming work but I don't
I've been training a lot of people I've
been training a lot of people what time
do you train from like six to eight I
came from like five to nine
slam dunk bro I recently got three pugs
but it took a it's I think it took a lot
a long time to get there and also like
um yeah we've I mean we've been we've
had twos and ones before and we came up
from there and then like wow you've been
as bad as
damn yeah
I'm either way out
huh yeah and we wanted to get here and
when you have a kid you see a whole
nother Dimension out of yourself and
your partner
stupid ass yeah you see like a whole
different side and you're just like wow
that's that's from father to father huh
yeah let's see that other side yeah me
and Bart we talk all the time man and
talk about
that this bit is so stupid so stupid
it's because there really are people who
believe their cat or dog is like makes
them apparent yeah and they try to
relate with real parents with that [__]
dude and the real pants are just like
and they try to move on to the
conversation but then they keep bringing
it up
so I guess this table is the winner for
having the highest average
you get a one dude I don't know it was a
competition guys yeah it was it was
sorry
foreign